كانت قصته من واقع الحياه لكنها الهمت
خيال صناع السينما انه مهران كريم ناصري
اللاجئ الايراني
في باريس سنوات طويله بعد ما منع من
الدخول الى فرنسا وبريطانيا لعدم توفره
على وثائقه تثبت وضعه كلاجي
ها هو يروي قصته حين ذاك عام 99
ان يعيش احد عشر عاما في وضع انت هذا انا
قصه هجره فريده تقدمت بالتماسات لاربعه
الحكومات بعضها كلنا بالنجاح والبعض الاخر
حاله فريده من نوعها
كل متاعه من الدنيا كان مخزنا في صناديق
واكياس في عربه المطار كان يغتسل ويحرق
ذقنه في حمامات المطار فقد الرجل الوثائق
التي تثبت وضعه كلاجئ خلال توقفه في باريس
عام 88
وكان ذلك يعني انه لا يمكنه السفر ولا
مغادره المطار فاسس حياه في محطه الركاب
رقم واحد
تحول مهران الى شخصيه رمزيه لا سيما انه
كان موضوع العديد من التقارير التلفزيونيه
والاذاعيه الفرنسيه والاجنبيه قبل ان تلهم
قصته المخرج الشهير ستيفن الذي حولها الى
فيلم عام 2004 بعنوان
او مبنى الركاب
ادى دور البطوله في الفيلم الممثل توم
هانكس
حصل مهران على صفه لاجئ في فرنسا وتصريح
اقامه عام 99
لكنه فضل البقاء في المطار حتى عام 2006
لينتقل بعدها الى العيش في نزول في باريس
مستخدما جزء من الاموال التي حصل عليها
نظير الفيلم
مسؤول في المطار قال انه عاد للعيش فيه
قبل عده اسابيع حيث كان على موعد مع القدر
في المساحه التي اسسها لنفسه اسفل السلم
المتحرك بالمطار
مات مهران ميته طبيعيه عن عمر لاهز سته
وسبعين عاما